Traductor: Mónica Martín Palmas
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Los seres humanos están por todas partes.
Con asentamientos en todos los continentes
estamos presentes en los rincones
más aislados de las junglas de la Tierra,
en océanos
y tundras.
Nuestro impacto es tan profundo
que la mayoría de científicos opina
que la huella de la humanidad en la
historia geológica terrestre es indeleble.
¿Qué ocurriría si de pronto
desaparecieran todos los humanos?
Sin nadie para mantenerlas, muchas
creaciones en seguida dan problemas.
Horas después de nuestra desaparición,
las refinerías de petróleo fallan,
produciendo incendios de un mes
en plantas como las del oeste de la India,
el sur de EE.UU.
y Corea del Sur.
En los sistemas de metro
como el de Londres,
Moscú
o la ciudad de Nueva York,
se abandonan cientos de bombas de drenaje
que inundan los túneles en tres días.
Al final de la primera semana, la mayoría
de generadores de emergencia se apagan
y una vez extinguidos los incendios,
la Tierra queda a oscuras
por primera vez en siglos.
Tras el catastrófico primer mes,
los cambios son más graduales.
En 20 años las aceras se agrietan a causa
de hierbas y raíces de los árboles.
Al mismo tiempo,
los túneles inundados erosionan las calles
y las convierten en ríos.
En climas templados,
el ciclo de las estaciones congela
y descongela estas corrientes,
agrietando el pavimento
y los cimientos de hormigón.
Las tuberías que gotean causan
el mismo efecto en edificios de cemento
y pasados 200 inviernos, la mayoría
de rascacielos se inclinan y se derrumban.
En ciudades situadas
en deltas fluviales como Houston,
estos edificios son barridos totalmente
y llenan los afluentes cercanos
de cemento triturado.
Las áreas suburbanas y rurales
se deterioran más lentamente
pero de maneras realmente sorprendentes.
Plagas de fugas, moho,
insectos y roedores,
todas ellas enemigos comunes
de propietarios de inmuebles
ahora campan a sus anchas.
En 75 años la mayoría de pilares maestros
de las viviendas están podridos y hundidos
y el montón de escombros resultante
es el hogar de lagartijas y roedores.
En este mundo post humano,
"local" tiene un nuevo significado.
Las ciudades están llenas
de plantas importadas
que crecen sin control
en sus hogares de acogida.
Los jacintos de agua cubren las aguas de
Shanghái como una gruesa alfombra verde.
El venenoso heracleum gigante invade
las orillas del río Támesis de Londres.
Los ailantos chinos crecen frondosos
en las calles de Nueva York.
Los rascacielos derrumbados aportan
cemento triturado al suelo del bosque,
cuya acidez cae en picado,
permitiendo así
que una nueva flora prospere.
Esta diversidad posthumana
se extiende también al reino animal.
Los animales exploran las extensiones
inexploradas de plantas nuevas y viejas,
adentrándose en nuevos hábitats
con la ayuda de los restos de puentes.
En general, nuestras infraestructuras
salvan a unos animales y condenan a otros.
Las cucarachas siguen prosperando
en su hábitat tropical original,
pero sin los sistemas de calefacción,
sus primas de la ciudad se congelan
y se extinguen en tan sólo dos veranos.
La mayoría de animales domesticados
no pueden sobrevivir sin nosotros,
salvo un puñado de cerdos,
perros y gatos callejeros espabilados.
En cambio, la menor contaminación lumínica
salva unos mil millones de pájaros al año,
cuyas migraciones se habían interrumpido
por las luces de torres de comunicación
y los cables de alta tensión.
Los mosquitos se multiplican sin fin
en una de sus cunas humanas favoritas,
los neumáticos, que duran
como mínimo unos mil años.
A medida que la fauna y la flora prosperan
el clima de la Tierra se recupera
del impacto humano de miles de años.
En 35 000 años
el ciclo de las plantas elimina
los últimos restos de plomo
dejados por la Revolución Industrial
en el suelo de la Tierra,
y podrían necesitarse
hasta 65 000 años más
para que los niveles de CO2
volviesen a niveles prehumanos.
Incluso pasados varios millones de años,
el legado de la humanidad persiste.
Tallado en granito inmutable,
el monte Rushmore sobrevive
durante 7,2 millones de años.
La composición química
de nuestras esculturas de bronce
las mantiene reconocibles
durante 10 millones de años.
Y enterrados en las profundidades,
los restos de las ciudades
construidas en llanuras inundables
se conservan en el tiempo
como un tipo de tecnofósiles.
Finalmente, esos restos también serán
barridos de la superficie del planeta.
La humanidad no siempre ha estado aquí
y no seguirá aquí eternamente.
Pero investigar el mundo sin nosotros
quizá nos permita aprender más
sobre el mundo en el que vivimos ahora.